so
kpunen
from Sweden the great
flag knowledge I had the variant
on the board recently and
I had a lot of difficulties with
black. Let's see if it's any better this time.
It doesn't seem to be good either.
I now have the
impression that it isn't
It's difficult for white to play right now, it's just
stupid to put the knight after D6
I have to
either lay it out more accurately or study it a little more
closely.
That's really very unpleasant
here, but it's nice to be different. Now I have to
keep an eye on the simple C6,
so
I get two or three moves here
and he doesn't know that he
has tempo moves again  but unfortunately he has
a lot of knights B5 e.g. then it would be
halfway possible but he's just
so fast
here
mhm yes he's certainly
not stupid in some way so okay he wants to
take he would like to take E5 here and then take E5
maybe I can play rook D8 and
then  To
take D6 here too, of course, he has
several developments that are good for
him, even easy. Knight C8 is good.
Knight C8 and swapping everything around, he
has the one, so
that's definitely not the best continuation.
Objectively, I think Knight B5 is still the
same
well, well at least he doesn't pull
the pace
so yes here maybe
here maybe dam B6 of
course really ugly no but
I can't give up A7 well either
no I mean it looks really
bad with the double pawn on the
lead line but maybe I have it  Also
with tur 8 there is a bit of
counterplay here, so white is definitely
much
better, maybe you can do a
little more,
although if he takes now and
then maybe knight C7 D6 then
I have nothing left, okay the
queen moves
away
h if I now  A6 do what does he do
then knight
D knight die6
probably well he'll come somehow
anyway
A6 knight D6 queen
A5 queen A5 knight
A5 yes super ugly position God God well
good but that's probably
not much to
do
now just knight C8 rook C8
Rook B6 with an excellent
endgame
aha doesn't take it on C8 I
think I would have done that in the spirit
of simplifying the position
but it's still not so that I
can move much here now so well
okay he wants to play B1 I could
run here  At the end he does runner
B7 and then the lights go
out, can I
somehow get another trick,
some trick,
I could do it for a moment, maybe that's
an
idea, try that, it's still a
very, very stupid idea, but let's see,
it probably works too  It wasn't
my idea to play knight C6
knight C6 yes, he can, he can
just take it, but
then it's no matter, yes the
position is broken, that's a really
terrible position for Black,
I haven't seen it at all, it's nice but of
course it wins too  Yes, no,
I have to play it differently now,
so that's where you're actually standing, um
really really
bad, it's not at all, you ca
n't fix it, the
position
is strange, the variation is actually has a really
good reputation for black, what am I obviously doing?
wrong but it's obvious I do
n't know what's wrong but
it's wrong so now now you have here
practically I actually have less
smooth rook
great hopes that the opponent will
actually
fall asleep at the desk and let the d-pawn through
well that  it's just kind of
bad
yes
yes unfortunately my
grandma thinks you should actually give up
but
somehow
t black
resign what's
bad here so that's how it's really
played
yes it's definitely more than
worthy of revision